بدات في روسيا حربها على اوكرانيا
بالتي صاروخنا مجنح كروز امريكيين كاليبر
روسيا لم تاتي المسيرات الايرانيه لخدمه
موسكو في الميدان الاوكراني الى بعد ان
يستنفذ الطيرسنتها ووصلت الى 120 صاروخا
اي ان روسيا استخدمت 200 صاروخ كالبر
شهريا في الاشهر العشره الاولى للحرب
129 مثلت انقادا للقدره الروسيه على
مواصلته زخم القصف خاصه تكلفتها المنخفضه
20 الف دولار ذلك
في روسيا بنزعج جهاز
النظام تحديد المواقع الروسيه المطور منذ
السبعينيات من قبل الجيش الاحمر ويستخدم
حاليا يستخدم حاليا اثنتين 22 قمر
وايران تحمل شراكه دفاعيه وتكنولوجيه
الشامله بحسب معهد واشنطن لسياسات الشرق
الادنى فهذه الشركاء او التوسع نطاقها
قائم على نظام المكافاه وسداد الديون
تعويضا عسكريا مؤكد ولويا محتمل
ستزود روسيا ايران بطائرات مقاتله انظمه
الدفاع جوي طائرات هليكوبتر فضلا عن
مساعدات بحريه في المجالات العسكريه على
شكل سفن حربيه او المساعده في انتاج السفن
جديده وهكذا يتوقع معهد واشنطن اكثر ما
يقلق الغربه واسرائيل على وجه الخصوص
4 التصدي لاي ضربات اسرائيليه محتمله ضد
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه والذي صرح
المسؤولون الروس مرارا انهم على استعدادا
لبيعه اللي ايران
اضافه الى 24 طائره سخوي 35 ستحصل عليها
ايران في مارس ومن شانها ان تقوي موقف
ايران في مواجهه اي تهديدات جويه لهذا
جاءت منورات اسرائيليه امريكيه كبرى ليست
روتينيه وهي الاضخم بين الطرفين منذ عقدين
تشارك فيها سفن وقد فادت قدره نوويه هي
تنتهي اليوم ولم يكن الحديث حول محاكاتها
لضرب مواقع نوويه ايرانيه من فراغ على
الاقل بالاستناد الى ما قاله مايكل اريك
كورولا قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
الغرب من هذا التمرين هو ارسال رساله الى
الاعداء مثل النظام الايراني
[موسيقى]